yesterday was our first day back after
our holiday break and Andy I didn't get
to ask you yesterday how was your
weekend
well oh it's pretty good I I didn't do
much how was yours
mostly uh hung out at home but get this
I smoked a beef brisket for 12 hours and
I have never done that before
Oh bad I love brisket I knew it
what good to know that you love brisket
Andy
cuz I brought in a brisket sandwich
today yeah really looking forward to it
put it in the fridge on the second floor
guess what now it's gone
you just said you love brisket maybe you
took it I did not take it didn't take it
huh well we'll find out if that's true
you see Andy the thief whoever that may
be left behind a small portion of
brisket sandwich on the third floor on
the way to your office
can we please stop with the stupid music
suspense things yeah sure Billy no more
suspense things yeah alright okay
so you found a morsel of brisket on the
third floor that doesn't mean anything
doesn't mean anything huh
well you know who may have an opinion on
whether this means anything or not
that's right everybody FBI forensics
technician Sheila Paulson hello Sheila
hello you brought the FBI into this yes
I did Andy cuz this is important crime
is crime Sheila what do we know well
Conan that piece of sandwich you gave me
earlier did indeed have a DNA sample so
you're going you're going to
cross-reference it with a criminal
database
as well as everyone who works here is
that right yes sir
and this state-of-the-art DNA sequencing
projector will in a matter of seconds
give us a full 3d rendering of the
perpetrator okay all right here we go
ready for this would you like to do the
honors I would love to press the button
and let's see what we're talking about
here
ah well what do you have to say for
yourself
Andy That's not me Andy it's clearly you
no no it is it it's Hank from the
control room
excuse me FBI are you Hank
yes I'm hey what's this about hey take
it easy
sorry Andy hi bad
it's okay Bank is handsome anyway that
sketch cost a $600,000